there is a distinction to be made where
it's like sure maybe you don't cancel
you know them forever sure people can make changes
and improve and come back we've seen that happen
but the first step towards that is embracing your
situation and removing yourself for a while so
you can do that work and heal yeah and then
come back and show that you've done the work
i feel like there's a lot of apology coming from
people online with little conspiracies of oh it
was provoked by this or oh the couple dropped the
restraining order because of that but i'm like if
you have to come up with a conspiracy or or some
kind of you know out there reason to explain
one after another after another event like
this i feel like you have to look at the
subject and go maybe there's something wrong
with that person that needs to be addressed
ezra ezra ezra miller you say ezra's name three
times and he ezra will show up to punch you i'll
assault come into your hotel room in the middle
of night and take your passport dude stop getting
arrested please stop getting arrested stop
assaulting people the more this happens the
longer we have to wait to see the flashbacks
yes that's what's truly important i will put
aside all these things about you as long as we
can sit there for two hours and watch the flash
and forget about real life and people's we will
do it millions of people across the globe do it
all right guys let's get a little serious first
things first a lot of people were correcting
us in the comments i was not aware of this
ezra miller has specifically chosen pronouns
okay so there's there's no more he they it's
just only they them now i believe so okay so
this is us learning to be respectful i can't
remember my talk a little bit slower just to make
sure i'm being respectful not to sincerely ezra
miller however to the community though as much as
there's people out there who like object against
that like who freaking pronouns i'll i'll do my
best to respect it okay it's not that big a deal
it's not that big a deal i just got it remember
so ezra miller was uh reportedly arrested
for a second time here's a fun fact miller is
scheduled to be in court tuesday to enter a plea
on harassment and disorderly conduct charges that
is pertaining to ezra's first arrest now as we've
been arrested a second time if you guys don't know
of what's been happening with ezra miller we'll
journey back a few years ago ezra choked the fan
and we never heard anything about what happened
now in hawaii ezra reportedly was behaving
violently at a bar at someone and yell at some
people there's another report that ezra broke into
a couple's home stole some belongings threatened
them that couple filed a restraining order dropped
the restraining order who knows why ezra was
really provoked at the bar who knows why that
couple dropped the restraining order maybe they're
big fans of zack snyder's justice league who knows
what's happening people are getting paid off i
don't know i don't want to spend my time dealing
with conspiracies or speculation i'm just going
to go off of the facts that are being reported
in the news and the articles and what's being
reported is ezra's doing some [ __ ] some violent
actions and is getting in trouble albeit seems
to be pretty light for ezra miller how ezra's
getting in trouble what's happening with the
second arrest reportedly it's for second-degree
assault comes from rolling stone per police report
during an investigation police identified miller
as the suspect and determined that they became
irate after being asked to leave and reportedly
threw a chair striking a 26 year old female in the
forehead resulting in an approximate half inch cut
the victim declined medical treatment what because
of a check from the wb this all happened at a
residence apparently in pahoa this is a serious
serious charge our days of making excuses for ezra
are done they were done for me a while ago back
with that first sentence man they really gotta
be done now yeah this is unacceptable of course
what's the first thing that uh i do when i hear of
such i think i go online i just want to like see
oh my god how are people responding to this and
it's exactly what happened before same exact thing
that happens every time i don't know why this is
everyone's first concern is replace replace esther
miller with grant gustin remember the first choice
remember what's really important here guys all
right we need that flash movie who cares about
the people who are being hurt circumstances are
one thing but we can't stop the movie business
secondly the other thing that i see is while
there's people who are like yeah ezra ezra ought
to be fired there's this other really big camp of
people who seem so concerned about ezra's mental
health now mental health is something i take very
very seriously i took mental health serious before
mental health was such a popular keyword out there
all right i've been in therapy for like 10 years
i take that [ __ ] super super serious i've never
been anywhere near on the level of pressure that
i imagine someone like ezra miller has had to
deal with with these huge profile films being
in the public spotlight whatever it may be all
right bottom line is though while i do think ezra
miller certainly has mental health struggles
i believe anyone who is consistently caught
doing this type of behavior has mental health
struggles i don't really side with the whole
victimizing ezra in the public spotlight if you
feel sympathetic towards whatever struggles ezra
may have i get that i do i i totally get it even
for me i feel a little bit bad for ezra sure just
because whatever this individual may be going
through might be extremely rough i don't know
ezra personally 99.9 percent of the people who
are very sympathetic towards ezra don't know him
personally they probably just really like his work
a lot which fine totally fair bottom line though
i do believe a it's really messed up how warner
brothers just is so tight-lipped about all this
i think it's really messed up they've kept amber
heard on freaking awful man dealing with the whole
ray fisher situation like there's a whole bunch
of drama that wb deals with they love jk rowling
they seem to wait for the court of public
opinion to sway to the point where people are
so upset that they have to act and then that's
when they actually act it's weird because ezra
gets this like superstar treatment wb just be
like just don't say anything you stop anything
like how did we need ezra ezra it's our money
maker what is happening how did they wind up in
that position in the first place i mean obviously
some good performances some good roles but like
that is i associate with being like superstar like
you're an institution and it's like a real big
business threat if we don't have you in the
fold kind of behavior at least from the studio
and i don't see how esther rose to that status i
think ezra miller ought to be relieved from the
projects moving forward i i full heartily actually
believe that hey there has to be consequences for
this type of action this whatever mental health
struggles ezra miller has that doesn't matter like
will smith for example clearly has probably some
mental health struggles and did something pretty
messed up at the oscars and is now suffering the
consequences for that action ezra miller should
get the same exact treatment doesn't matter if
it wasn't at some big televised event this is a
consistent pattern ezra miller should suffer some
consequences from this in order for ezra miller
for all those who really are sympathetic
towards his plight everyone should realize
that if ezra continues to get these big jobs that
is only enabling his behavior because ezra can
keep getting away with this type of behavior if
ezra is still allowed to keep working often times
when you start to lose something that means ah
i really need to like check myself in and start
getting some real help in order to come back in
the spot like like a robert downey jr situation
in a way there comes a point in time where it's
like you got to stop feeling sorry for someone
and start going you need to take responsibility
for your actions and you need to do something
about it and with that comes sacrificing some
other stuff absolutely and i mean i understand
the sympathy people want to have toward a person
clearly demonstrating some sort of mental anguish
or mental you know health struggle and i feel
like there is a pollution of that conversation by
you know the way we all get up in arms about who
cancel culture and why people are removed from the
spotlight or not but i've heard fame described
by others as a unique kind of trauma which you
know obviously you know a person in ezra miller's
position very blessed you know gets to you know
enjoy the finest things in life probably but at
the same time it's a grind there's a lot you have
to put yourself through mentally and physically
and it's you know a lot more than just showing
up on set and pretending for a few days while
necessarily it's not the same thing as going like
oh you know cancel this you know truly malicious
evil person or something like that it's more we
should remove them from this situation so that
they can get the help they actually need instead
of being in this position where they're prone to
being overloaded or whatever is motivating this
it's hard to be under that big of a microscope
and yeah i wouldn't be surprised if people are
being sort of paid to contain this situation
or whatever but it keeps happening and in such
a tight cluster i don't think you can really
deny that that's not a healthy person to have
in a workplace and every movie is a workplace and
every workplace is made up of people trying to
just do their job right and this gets in the way
of all of that and it bleeds out into just regular
life and so yeah while i feel like some people
are like i want to take sympathy on the guy and
i don't want him to have him canceled or something
like that i feel like there is a distinction to be
made where it's like sure maybe you don't cancel
you know them forever sure people can make changes
and improve and come back we've seen that
happen but the first step towards that is
embracing your situation and removing yourself
for a while so that you can do that work and
heal and then come back and show that you've
done the work i feel like there's a lot of
apology coming from people online with little
conspiracies of oh it was provoked by this or oh
the couple dropped the restraining order because
of that but i'm like if you have to come up with
a conspiracy or or some kind of you know out there
reason to explain one after another after another
event like this i feel like you have to look at
the subject and go maybe there's something wrong
with that person that needs to be addressed i
believe in a good comeback story but in order
for there to be a comeback there has to be a going
away first yeah yeah don't implode on yourself and
yes have that be the going out this is destructive
behavior this has to change and ezra shouldn't be
rewarded with millions of dollars per film you
know bottom line because that's ridiculous in
their biggest franchises and is about to be three
roles in a pivotal movie for them which i get as a
studio is hard how do you deal with that but it's
only getting worse the less they deal with yeah
all right guys well what do you think should ezra
be let go should we just give the wb like a little
pat on the back here what do you think should
happen nothing nothing nothing he goes free scott
yeah just keep on keeping on fantastic piece four
all right guys well we'll talk with you guys soon
you